the world has 250 trillion dollars of
debt which is a lot of it is credit but
we only have around 50 trillion dollars
of currency how is that possible you
know what I'm asking right we have 50
trillion dollars of coins and currency
we have a quarter trillion dollars that
250 trillion dollars of debt we have a
lot of good faith based on the the
prowess of the US printing press I mean
the United States maintains reserve
currency status
that's very money though that's not real
money that's fake money that's true I
don't show your knowledge of fake money
oh really
I know but it's all based on faith how
long is this now how long is it
sustainable though how to go at that
pace in theory and if you listen to what
you're being told everything's going to
be ok trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars with the United
States and the lead the United States by
far visa vie any other countries taking
on more debt to address the coronavirus
than anybody else on the planet
including China that's saying something
and we're being told that it's all going
to be fine because you can just have the
Federal Reserve which is what they're
going to do this year finance all debt
that's being taken on put all of it on
their balance sheet we came into this
with the Federal Reserve's balance sheet
somewhere in the neighborhood of four
trillion it is likely that we will get
into double digits trillion dollar it's
a scary thought you know I'm looking at
all this stuff and to me everything's
the leaders bulletin and I think
someone's going to come out to winner
here from coronavirus I do think this is
showing us that we need a strong leader
oh I think behind closed doors there is
and I'm gonna go to an empire that I'm
looking at that it's gonna be crazy for
me to give them credit but strategically
I think they have been poised for this
to come up so here's some data here
China's national debt is five point two
trillion dollars that's what they have
right and their GDP at their debt to GDP
but before I get into this
how much do you as an economist look at
the debt to GDP ratio is that a big
factor do you look at that as a big
factor or not really it's not a big
concern I think it's a huge concern it
is so yeah and now that we know that
it's truly Milton Friedman behind me
yeah I always adhered to his philosophy
that there is no such thing as a free
lunch you can buy time I mean God knows
we've seen a lot of time purchased
bought but we haven't seen it paid for
so yes I think that there will be
ramifications okay so when you're saying
that as an economist you do look at
nations and say Japan's at 221 percent
debt to GDP ratio they're about to have
a massive recession taking place that's
gonna take them a couple decades to
recover do you go to extreme measures
when you see numbers like that or it's
not a measure point that you look at and
say that's a very big factor well it
really is a country-by-country basis and
I don't want to I'm not trying to back
out of the question but internally in
Japan they own their own debt their
fates not necessarily tied to other
countries which means that they're not
beholding to the kindness of strangers
unlike the United States where Japan
owns a trillion dollars of US Treasury
debt China owns over a trillion dollars
of US Treasury debt we assume that we
can take on as much debt as we possibly
can imagine and that our borrowing costs
will never go up because we just assume
that we're number one it to elaborate
what you just said is that is that in a
sense of saying you know we're married
we have a family the bed David family
only borrows money from bed David family
okay that's Japan but us the family here
borrows money from anybody
strangers whoever's I can't is that a
good way of putting over Japan versus us
because we'll borrow from anybody and we
also borrow from ourselves and we the
Treasury issues it and the Federal
Reserve buys it so then if that's the
case let me give you this number and
tell me what you think about this
China's in debt five point two trillion
Brazil's at two trillion Japan's got
nine trillion and if you look at the
debt to GDP ratio Japan's at the top of
221 Greece 179 which would pretty much
know why Portugal 138 Italy 138 Belgium
115 u.s. 106 Spain 106 UK 86 France 98
point for Germany 62 you ready for this
number Russia 17% and they bought 400
tons of gold the last couple years a lot
of these nations that have their gold
have been sitting on the same amount of
gold for a while but Russia has been
coming up on the gold leaders bulletin
why are they at
17% their debt by the way Russia's debt
is 217 billion I don't have it written
anywhere here but you don't have any
billions on your page you're only half
trillion trillions Russia is only a two
hundred seventeen point three billion
dollars as of February of 2020 I believe
mm-hmm
are they looking at the saying we're
gonna make a vertical move in the next
couple years too because we're a little
bit more responsible than others or no
that doesn't mean anything so people ask
me all the time because if you look at
if you if you study the way people think
and I'm talking about without naming any
name is the Socialists say that we can
print as much money as we want that lets
say that our debt right now is twenty
five trillion let's round up given what
we know we've just spent as a nation but
the Socialists the the universal basic
income say that you can easily double it
and because we have reserve currency
status and because we have not seen
inflation in generations we're gonna get
away with it and our borrowing costs are
never going to rise and as long as our
borrowing costs never rise and inflation
never rear its ugly head then we can
borrow to kingdom come
and when these things work they work
until they don't work but at some point
if the rest of the world begins to push
back let's say certain countries emerge
stronger from this global recession than
others it tends to be if you're going to
make a move it tends to be he who has
dry powder the least amount of debt the
most hard assets is able to assume more
leverage and power than they otherwise
would based on looking at the size of
the country's economy in other words to
your point Russia has not weakened their
balance sheet they've strengthened it
and their long term planners China's a
long term planner as well China has a
ton of debt but China also has been a
lender to many nations with natural
resources throughout the world and
quietly been colonizing a big portion of
the world and they happen to have an
ally in Russia so you can connect many
dots no doubt about it
theoretically no doubt
but all of this debt we're taking on
does weaken our position on the global
stage
[Music]